what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch the
trailer for knock at the cabin Johnny
Bear how's it going I'm good how are you
sir I'm doing well uh we're shooting
this like four in the morning right now
uh it came out while we were filming
She-Hulk but it's an M Night Shyamalan
movie I was like yeah let's watch the
trailer for this you only I'm not
Shyamalan movie I haven't seen is the
movie old have you seen old Samesies no
I haven't movie reaction incoming sounds
like it as if this wasn't already part
of my master plan ladies and gentlemen
if you could leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated anywho let's see what's
in store
[Music]
[Music]
all right
oh we're gonna sing along
Jonathan Groff hey
Logan shoes
[Music]
[Music]
is that Dave Bautista
bigfooting out in the woods
hearing
my name is Leonard
what's nice to meet you one
why are you here
it's for dads too
love those sharks
because of what I have to do today
[Music]
and a mallet head
see the four of us have a very important
job to do
in fact it might be the most important
job
history of the world
no
Rupert Grint
and are united by a common vision
which has now become a command
and we cannot ignore
hey
over here
prevent the Apocalypse
has to make a horrible decision
if you fail to choose
the world went
out of a trailer damn surely
oh no oh wow I was like three writers on
that hey that's that's good that's
heartening
sometimes someone can sway you know yeah
I feel like Shyamalan needs a couple
people around to bounce things off of to
temper his uniqueness a little bit well
I was reading up a little bit on this
movie and it's interesting like it's
based on a book that I forget the book's
got the cabin at the end of the world
and it might be what it's called I don't
know if I'm wrong there'll be a text
here odds are this discussion is going
to be uncut because of the hour that
we're filming but uh yeah that that it's
based on a book and what I learned
recently is that a lot of times when
books get published is usually in order
to get a book published you have to have
the movie deal done or the movie rights
sold in advance before publishing and
that was kind of the case with this
movie first and apparently that's how
you usually get a book published
nowadays
I learned that from an author not long
ago and I was like wow that's pretty
nuts that you have to usually have that
in place first and that's how you get
the publishing going so anyway
um yeah this was kind of sitting in
development hell like what's one of
those movies that was just never getting
produced and then Shyamalan came across
the script that was already written and
then he took capacity and rewrote it and
I thought it was under just two writers
apparently there's three and he was like
this is the fastest script I've ever
written and I was like oh cool so he's
got like a lot of faith in what this
property is and apparently the book is
really cool and beloved so yeah I don't
know much about the actual plot I know
more about that stage which I thought
was really fascinating but for what
we're getting here it's different than a
lot of the other Shyamalan movies but in
the same sense of big picture but very
contained environment that's uh
something I think Shyamalan actually
really excels in is something massive
like he's got his apocalyptic horror
movie
but it's also a home invasion Thriller
and that's like the main focus and
thrust of it and is this apocalyptic
thing real is it a cult like at least
that's the vibe of what the trailer is
getting I know I could probably just
read the book and find out but in terms
of like the mood and the tone and the
sound design of what we got I thought
this was like an excellent excellent
trailer and you know if you didn't tell
me it was Shyamalan I wouldn't have
guessed yeah I know right
funny yeah I mean this kind of reminded
me I don't know if these are the exact
you know most uh you know on the money
polls but I kept thinking of funny games
meets the box or something like that
where it's like yeah you have this
simple yeah it's like a nice getaway
with this intimate family setting and oh
it's just the three of us we're gonna go
and have a nice time and then all of a
sudden these people show up and invade
their lives and then yeah put them
through this harrowing experience of
whatever variety this here apocalyptic
variety and uh yeah it got me intrigued
in the good way that M Night stories can
and I love the idea of something like
this that seems like it while you know
we'll certainly have some kind of twist
I don't know
I like being in the position of not
knowing whether this is just these four
people's cultish delusion or whether it
is really some kind of actual
world-rending Stakes that are going to
be brought forth and uh yeah I mean just
the performance is Alone look really
engrossing and I love the way that the
lensing is like really calling your
attention to the glass and like the
distance between things when they're
racking and stuff that's the most well I
was like I'm it's the most akin to like
that I would have picked up on well if
you get those looming shots of like the
trees and you get that Crush Zoom uh
thing you're just looking through a
Thicket and I I've started to think of
the happening but luckily this feels
like you know something much more
grounded to then uh you know
counterweight whatever High concept
conclusion there's gonna be because I
have to imagine that there's going to be
something of a high concept idea at work
at the end of it all well what I imagine
knowing background I haven't seen old
but knowing what Shyamalan normally does
a lot of his themes seem to be about the
power of belief and faith and I feel
like there's something of that theme
that's going to be applied to that
little girl toad well yeah and I mean
it's the most like estimate best
estimate I could give about knowing
shyamalan's previous work and what he
likes to toy with yeah it's like I bet
somehow her Purity and her you know
non-corrupted view of the world will
probably play in and I bet that you know
dads for as well meaning as they might
be are probably going to get in the way
with you know all that conditioning well
what I really I'm loving right now is
the career of Dave Bautista sure because
I I think it was like when he had that
one scene in Blade Runner 2049 when he
did that one scene and it's crazy how
that one scene left such a germinating
impact for that man's career because
like we all saw him as you know Drax
when he when he transition to film which
was really funny and everything but when
he did that you're like oh this guy's
got like real dramatic acting jobs and
then the range he's been able to display
ever since has been incredibly
consistent he can do pretty much any
genre and you wouldn't think of that for
a man of his look and his stature his
kind of build but he really can do it he
can do it all and then like the
direction he's chosen to take with his
career I think is really fascinating and
then seeing his role here it just it
fits it really fits because this guy
looks Disturbed you don't know if he's
telling the truth or not I mean like he
believes it looks like he believes what
he's saying which is what's important
for a character like that but also with
having his build it makes it that much
scarier we're normally I'd Associated
character like that with not having such
a build they might usually be kind of
like long-haired beard skinny I don't
know yeah something like the word for it
yeah so I think there's something fresh
about it yeah you have like the gay dads
which you know you're seeing a lot of
home invasion movies before more and
like that adds a little bit of a fresh
take to it and then having someone like
Dave like everyone else in the group
Rupert grinton and the other people they
all look like what you usually see in
that kind of crew yeah exactly but David
Bautista
um is is such a unique look for that
kind of character and it works at least
in this trailer it's really working for
me so yeah I don't know
I like it I like it I like I like to
quite a bit one two I love when anything
can take something that's really
commonplace and make it scary and
unnerving and the knocking sound like
the way they use the knocking sound and
how claustrophobic and in your like
right up in the mix it is uh I'm looking
forward to that I like a good harsh but
well chosen sound design yeah I haven't
seen it comes at night but I think it
kind of feels like that trailer sure
yeah go to that quiet place five is or
anything in the woods yeah
macro shots of bugs and things and I'm
sure that'll be a motif because the
little girls cataloging bugs exactly
exactly yeah I like this trailer what'd
you guys think leave your thoughts down
below uh be sure to subscribe leave a
like click that Bell we will see you all
soon
[Music]